I have part of a plan what percentage of  a plan do you have you don't get to ask  questions after the nonsense you pulled  on knowhere  I just saved quill we've already  established that you destroying the ship  that I'm on is not saving me what do we  Estelle like three seconds ago no listen  listen man thinking there's something  else oh she's right you don't get an  opinion what percentage I don't know  12% 12% it's real  totally fake that is the most real  authentic hysterical laugh of my entire  life because that is not a plan barely a  concept you're taking their side I am  Groot so what it's better than 11% what  the hell does that have to do with  anything  Thank You Groot thank you see roots the  only one of you who has a clue